you reach adulthood and suddenly you're
spending like at least a third of your
life pursuing money and people are
talking about mortgage rates and swap
rates and bond yields and this and that
and other it's like and you're just
expecting to know what it all means but
will you ever talk to it I never was
today I'm joined by Rob Dix now Rob is
an investment fund advisor and he's the
co-presenter of one of the UK's most
popular business podcasts called the
property podcast Rob is also the
co-author of The Ultimate Guide to
property investing which is the Bible of
property investing in the UK and his
most recent book is called the price of
money how to prosper in a financial
world that's rigged against you I
realized that I'd been working in and
around money for about 10 years and I
didn't really understand where money
came from how it works and all the rest
of it and if I didn't then what chance
does anyone else have in this
conversation we kind of split up into
three parts in the first part we talk
about what money is and how money works
and some of the complications around
things like inflation and interest rates
and the cost of living crisis and the
conclusion really of the first part of
the conversation is that we live in a
financial world that is rigged against
normal people like you and me the core
core thing that it's important to
understand and why you could say it's
rigged against you if you're guaranteed
to lose buying power by saving money
then that's not good then in the second
part of the conversation we talk about
Rob's five principles for being able to
prosper in a financial world that's
right against us and then we end with a
bit of a discussion around property and
around business specifically ultimately
what you earn is kind of a multiple of
how much value you create and how many
people you can reach to create that
value for your earning power especially
when you're young is the best financial
asset you can ever have hey friends so
before we get into the episode I've got
some very exciting news that I'm finally
able to share with you and that is that
I have written a book now if you've been
following the podcast for a while you'll
probably know from some of my
conversations with authors in particular
that has been quite the journey over the
last three years this has been the
single hardest thing that I've ever done
in my life but after three years it's
finally here and I'm delighted to
announce that my book feel good
productivity is now available for
pre-order it's going to be published
later this year and you can find a link
down in the video description or if you
head over to
feelgoodproductivity.com all one word
you can check out the website and the
website is absolutely sick now the
central idea for the book came from a
realization that I had while I was
working as a doctor a few years ago and
trying to juggle everything with my
YouTube channel and my business and I
kind of realized that the secret to
productivity isn't discipline it's in
fact joy and sure hard work and great
and willpower and determination and all
of those things are good in small doses
but for most of us they tend not to be
the sustainable route to consistent
productivity but I realized through a
lot of experimentation and then diving
into a bunch of research that actually
the secret to productivity that feels
enjoyable and meaningful and sustainable
is to find a way to make your work feel
good to find a way to make it feel
energizing and enjoyable and if you do
that you'll be more productive in your
work but you'll also have way more
energy to give to the other things in
your life that matter to you and this
isn't just my own personal experience
but it's an idea that's been validated
by a bunch of studies in the fields of
Psychology and Neuroscience as well and
so the writing process of the book over
the last three years has involved
reading hundreds of research papers
interviewing academics and experts in
the fields of like psychology and
procrastination and motivation and
spending years trying to condense it
into a format and cut out all the fluff
and try to do it in a way that's like
engaging and actionable at the same time
so that's what the book is about it is a
science back guide on how to do more of
what matters to you in a way that feels
enjoyable and meaningful and sustainable
and if you enjoy this podcast then I can
basically guarantee that you will love
the stuff that's in the book there are
nine chapters each chapter has six
different experiments in it that you can
try out in your own life and so there
are 54 different experiments strategies
that you can apply to your life starting
from as soon as you read the book and
the idea is that you apply these and you
see if they work for you and over time
you'll build your own feel-good
productivity system now if you do decide
to pre-order the book then that would be
awesome because firstly helps me out and
secondly I think the ideas in this book
can be genuinely life-changing and if
you pre-order the book it will be
delivered straight to you on release
date later this year or to your Kindle
or your audible account and I'm
narrating the audiobook by the way or to
their hardback hardback version of the
book If you prefer to read physical
copies of books and if you do pre-order
then please do be sure to save your
receipts because I'm going to be
announcing a bunch of really exciting
pre-order bonuses exclusively only for
people who pre-order the book and so
final thing before we get into the
episode is just want to say a massive
thank you to you guys by watching the
videos by subscribing on social media by
listening to the podcast you have made
this book possible
um without you guys supporting the
channel and everything that I do there's
no way penguin would have come knocking
and been like hey do you want to write a
book and so I'm like this has been like
such a rewarding experience and I could
not have gonna come to this point
without your support so I just wanted to
say massive thank you from the bottom of
my heart for that so that's it from me
do check out the book If you like at
feelgoodproductivity.com it'll be linked
Down Below in the podcast description
and the show notes as well for now let's
get into the podcast episode itself so
Rob thank you so much for coming on the
podcast thank you for having me this
feels like a pretty weird moment for me
because I've been listening to your
voice I since like I've been listening
to your voice since like 2017 when I
first got into the idea of property
investing through your podcast and then
I read the book that you and the other
Rob wrote uh The Ultimate Guide to
property investing or something like
that which literally taught me
everything I know about property
investing and I've also invested in four
properties through your company and so
when I saw that you'd written this book
work I was like oh sick we've got to
have you on the podcast so thank you so
much for coming on it's great to be here
and like since we after you read the
book I think it's I can't remember where
I sort of I think your name kind of
popped up as a bar I was like hang on
that's Ali because I was like watching
your stuff by then and so it's like yeah
you're kind of on weird parallel tracks
exactly so we're gonna talk all all
things money um so the type of your book
is the price of money how to prosper in
a financial world that's rigged against
you so I was thinking we start off
talking about kind of understanding the
whole money system and then I want to
talk about your five rules for kind of
money slash getting ready from slash
investing slash saving all that kind of
stuff yeah and then I was thinking in
the third part we would talk about all
things property
um you buy and also rent your property
which is kind of what I do so it'd be
interesting to talk about that and I'd
love to hear more about the economics of
the business you've created around the
idea of property investing sounds good
to me fantastic okay so why did you
decide to write a book about money
well I got interested in economics
around about 2008 because of the kind of
what the hell's Happening Here type
thing but I kind of was interested in it
as a as a hobby and then 2020 happened
which was like a weird year for every
possible reason but that's when like we
just had a Whole Decade of like there is
no Magic Money Tree it was a decade of
austerity it was all about getting rid
of the deficit and all that kind of
thing and it's like you know we've got
to keep saving money it just doesn't
just grow on trees then suddenly they
need an extra 450 billion pounds to
fight kobit they're like boom okay we've
got it 450 billion let's go and spend it
and let everyone paid everyone stay at
home pay for people to go out to each
remember that all this really weird
stuff it's like oh hang on a minute what
is going on here and I realized that I'd
been working in and around money for
like 10 years and I didn't really
understand where money came from how it
works and all the rest of it and if I
didn't then what chance does anyone else
have and so I just kind of wanted to get
to them unravel this mystery of what the
heck it's all about and I think so so
much of the time people kind of put it
in the two hard blocks and go well you
know it's all these very clever
economists all these fancy words I can't
possibly understand it but I had no real
qualifications I'm not particularly
smart I just kind of did a lot of
reading and figured it out and wanted to
kind of put it into a form to save
someone else doing all that reading and
so in like five hours they could get to
where I got to in 500 hours fantastic
um and so what was your understanding of
money growing up and I guess you know
viewers and listeners might be able to
relate to it because we're not really
taught a lot about money in school not
at all I mean I think we massively
inherit money blueprints from our
parents and so what you're you're kind
of you'll get all these all these weird
people weird about money as well right
like people have very strange attitudes
about it most of the time it doesn't
make logical sense people just kind of
have these beliefs and fears and things
around money that you kind of inherit
from the people around you when you're
young but you don't talk about it or at
least in my family I don't think most
families you end up talking about it and
then at school I think we might have had
like one lesson once ever had something
to do with it but that's about it lots
on oxbow lakes and stuff like that but I
think I'd actually something to be
useful and so you never really learn and
so you end up in this weird position
where you reach adulthood and suddenly
you're spending like at least a third of
your life pursuing money you don't
really know what it is and you're
expected to make all these decisions
about money and people are talking about
mortgage rates and swap rates and bond
yields and this and that never it's like
and you're just expecting to know what
it all means but will you ever talk to
it I never was no yeah I think it's like
um
it's still one of those things that you
know even though I've spent the last I
guess like six six or ten years building
a business that well you know by
definition is pursuing money to some to
some degree
I still have to really try and wrap my
head around okay interest rates interest
rates are going up what the frick does
that mean okay I vaguely understand
inflation but like two percent like why
is inflation good why is inflation bad
like why can't why can't we just print
more money again something about
inflation this like all of all of these
questions that like
I I find myself asking to friends who
are in finance and they have good
answers to them and I'm like okay I'm
just about keeping up and it it just it
gets pretty confusing pretty quickly
yeah it does and then even if you dig a
bit deeper if you ask a second or third
question it will often turn out that
those people don't really understand it
there's this kind of surface level
explanation but then if you go like a
couple of y's deep okay well why do we
have inflation why is it different then
it kind of unravels quite quickly and it
turns out that there kind of is no
answer or it's just well we've sort of
ended up here somehow but it's a very
scarily small proportion of people I
think you actually have any idea what's
going on and yet if you turn on the
radio just generally good idea not to do
but if you do then there's always like
people giving their opinions about
what's going to happen and explaining
what just has happened but most of it's
just like astrology I think it's just
like the markets went up yesterday why
well people want opinions but no one
knows it's like it's just weird Okay
some some people might say well fine I
know how to use a computer but I don't
need to understand how a computer works
I know how to use money I know how to
make money I know how to how to you
spend money but do I really need to
understand how it actually works and how
it gets created and stuff like that I
think you probably need to of what I
cover in the book you probably need to
know like a good 70 I'd say some of it
is kind of just for fun like it's kind
of cool to know that Banks just create
money out of thin air so if you go and
get a bank loan there's no concept of
like oh we'll just pop into the back and
see if we've got any money spare they
will literally create it out of nothing
that money never existed before and they
greeted it to give it to you that's kind
of cool that's weird
um but you don't need to know that but
then there are plenty of things that you
do need to know so like understanding
understanding things like the national
debt and inflation and all this sort of
stuff is really important because it
gives you clues about what the future is
going to be like and if you're going to
make the right decisions about your
money it's helpful to know or at least
some kind of clue about the path that
the future is going to take so if for
example people we are going to end up
having lots of inflation so the at the
moment I'm recording this there's loads
of inflation for a long time we were
being told it's just transitory it's
just it's just a thing it's covered it's
going to pass and now that seems like
it's not going to be the case and my
contention is going to continue to be a
lot higher than we think it think it
should be for quite a long time well
that's really helpful to know because
you can then make the the right
decisions about the Investments you make
and how you approach your finances with
that in mind but the thing about
understanding the actual principles
behind it and why that's the case is
then you don't have to take anyone's
word for it because like I said earlier
everyone's got an opinion so if you you
kind of you listen you speak to one
person they'll say oh this is going to
happen another person said well that's
going to happen they're both eminently
qualified economy sometimes they've got
two people with Nobel prizes both saying
the exact opposite of each other who do
you believe yeah the great thing about
actually understanding at the Grassroots
level is you don't view them don't have
to take anyone's word for it you can
come to your own view yeah yeah that
makes a lot of sense I think if I if I
think to you know people people I know
like my my mum for example who will move
uh Heaven and Earth to try and save a
few quid at Tesco and make sure that if
she'll like call me back when I've I've
driven off to Tesco because I haven't
taken the club card keychain with me to
grab the coupon thingy and yet for the
big financial decisions like getting a
mortgage uh she would have no idea what
the word interest rate even means and
what a mortgage even is and would take
the word of like one of our uncles who
maybe has a couple of properties and to
who would say that oh you know by buying
a property in London is what everyone
should do and should be like right guys
you should buy a property in London
and there was a huge financial decisions
that have enormous repercussions for
someone's entire life yeah uh and I
think
for a lot of people not understanding
what is actually going on means that at
best you make an uninformed decision
about these enormously big things and at
worst you make a terrible decision about
these enormously big things exactly and
it's almost too too intimidating and too
scary to think about and so you do just
end up taking someone else's word for it
because it's easier then people aren't
as weird about money in general so like
there are plenty of people you've got
plenty of multi-multi-millionaires who
will always drive back to collect the
club card because it's a principle of a
thing or they've just got these kind of
weird beliefs about it but I do kind of
a bigger structural level yeah it really
helps to actually understand it's not
and it's not that hard even people
people it's kind of made to be hard and
it's made to be boring and complicated
but it doesn't have to be okay nice so
let's get started um the price of money
how to prosper in a financial world
that's ridiculous that's rigged against
you I guess firstly
what is money and like where do we where
do we start this whole story
money is I've called it fiction because
it's something that we've collectively
agreed is a thing so like money money is
whatever we say it is so anything can be
money throughout history all kinds of
different things when money shells have
been money like sticks with like notches
carved them have been money anything
could be money it's just something kind
of stands between transactions that
we're making
because it makes things easier so we we
use the pound in this country the dollar
is like the global currency or why are
they the thing they they just because
everyone agrees and it's great if
everyone agrees on something because it
means that you can like go out and buy
pretty much anything you want when you
kind of both you've got an established
unit to use but it doesn't but money in
itself doesn't have any value like
through a lot of history money itself
had value so you have like gold coins so
the gold and the coin would be valuable
um or you'd be able to like the first
banknotes you could go and actually hand
that banknote in at the bank of England
and get a set amount of gold in return
so the money itself would have value but
for the and there's been times in
history when that's been stretched but
now money just is money is money because
we say it is and money is extremely
useful because if you didn't have it
then it would be a nightmare to get
anything done like how would you if you
wanted to to go and get your haircut you
couldn't just give them money you'd have
to find something that they wanted and
go and give it to them the whole thing
would be a nightmare but I think a kind
of a pro it's really useful to keep in
mind that money is effectively just
something that we are kind of a
collective very useful illusion because
then when things get weird which they do
when you start going deeper into money
it kind of helps you kind of realize why
that's the case and it breaks some of
the illusions that we have around like
the pound or the dollar having a fixed
value because they don't hmm yeah when I
when I was getting into all the crypto
stuff I I started reading into some of
this and you know the 1970s gold
standard and how money was pegged to
Gold but then it became not Peg to gold
and it sort of uh essentially the the
reason we believe in the US dollar is
because we believe in the US government
yeah I wonder if you can speak a little
bit about that for people who might not
be familiar with that side of the story
that's a really big deal so they so we
they've had like various things version
kind of versions of this thing called
the gold standard in the past but
effectively it's where like every where
currents you started to have like
initially gold was the currency yeah
coins made of gold and then you have
other currencies but those currencies
are pegged to a particular amount of
gold so the but first of all it was
still like the pound has its name
because it was a pound weight of silver
um but then over time that's going to
change and then at times of War you kind
of suspend all that and go well actually
we need to get a load of money so forget
that but then it always comes back to
being backed by something again but then
it was the so 1971 where it was the
first time that and temporarily this is
only meant to be temporary the the US
dollar was no longer worth a specific
amount of gold it was just worth
whatever it has value because we say it
is and this is this is on a temporary
basis over 50 years ago and that's a big
deal because when you have a currency
that is linked notionally to an amount
of gold then it puts a constraint on how
much of it can be created so that there
is only so much gold in the world
there's only so much of it you can pull
out of the ground every year and then it
gets progressively harder to pull it out
of the ground because you've kind of
used up all the easy stuff
so there's only so much extra money that
can be created when that's done away
with then well what is what's stopping
you if I'm just going and like printing
an extra few extra billion nothing at
all and so the result of that if we go
and look at the total money supply of
the US or the UK or pretty much anywhere
else you'll sort of see a line that's
completely flat that pretty much the
whole way through history then you get
to the 70s and it goes like that and it
just goes up like a hockey stick pattern
and that's because so much extra money
has been created in the last 50 years
and the magnitude of it is just shocking
I'd encourage anyone to go and look at a
chart on it just because it's just
Bonkers and it kind of makes you realize
okay the last 50 years it feels normal
to us because it's the only time we've
ever known but historically it's
completely abnormal and it's not going
to last forever it can't last forever
uh so apparently there's this quote from
Henry Ford uh if people understood how
our money and banking system worked
there'd be a revolution before tomorrow
morning what's what's going on there
well so he said that bear in mind before
a lot of the craziness has happened
recently but we've already kind of
touched on a couple of the key the key
points so like Banks can just create
money so you and I have to work for
money
um we try and arrange our lives so we
can get as much money as we can we're
working as little as we can but we have
to essentially work Banks can just
create it out of nothing it happens in
front of you and that's just that's nuts
that some some entities have the special
privilege to just create money yeah how
does that work why can't my business
just create money
because that would be illegal um and
that's all right for Barclays to do it's
okay for them to do it because it's it's
a it's a very it's a whole strange
complex thing but basically a banking
license is literally a license to print
money and so it allows you to to just
say yep I will you want to borrow this
money you want to borrow a thousand
pounds so I will I'll type a thousand
Pounds into your account and there's a
kind of a counter entry where it's it's
like that you owe it to them but it's
kind of their it's an asset it's a
liability it's it's but it's not it's
nonsense but they but they create money
that didn't exist before and when you
repay that loan the money ceases to
exist so that's weird
um and then
the fact that the states can just create
money as well so we saw talking about
2020 where the 450 billion that was
needed to fight covid which is created
the bank of England created it and gave
it to the government to spend and so
it's it's just absolutely nuts and then
if I think if most people realize this
you would get that whole thing of well
hang on a minute like how how is it that
I'm having to work so hard and all and
yet Money Can't other people can just
create money and the thing about it is
that when money is created it's the
people who are closest to the money
creation who tend to see the biggest
benefit of it and so then it'll pass its
way through the system and eventually by
the time it gets to your ordinary person
or someone else has already profited
from it and inflation means that by the
time it gets to you'll probably probably
be worth less anyway inflation is a
whole other type of weirdness that we
should talk about yeah okay
so is this what you mean by a financial
world that's rigged against you
there's one yes but there is one other
particular way in which it's been rigged
against most people recently which is
um when you inflation is something that
now everyone's very aware of but for a
long time no one really thought about
inflation much because it was like
ticking along a couple of percent a year
but when you when something happens for
a couple of percent a year for a lot of
years it compounds into something that's
quite a lot so the pound has lost half
its value in the last 20 years so that's
kind of weird so if you had so if you
had a 10 pound note and you got lost it
20 years ago found it today it would buy
you half as much stuff as it did 20
years ago
that wouldn't be so much of a problem if
you could put that money into the bank
and an amount of interest that
compensated for that and more yeah
because you'd still be coming out ahead
that for most of History that's been the
case the rate of interest has been
higher than the rate of inflation
but since 2009 that's not been the case
so at the moment people are feeling
pretty good about the fact that you can
get nearly four percent in an instant
access bank account that sounds pretty
good because we can remember when it was
nothing but inflation's eight percent
so you're actually losing even more than
you were before so the way that the
financial system is rigged against you
is that the money that you have is
losing money every year it's costing you
more to buy the things that you need
and by saving money there's nothing you
can do about it because even if you save
money your savings are guaranteed to be
losing value
but if you've got debt
then you see the other side of that
equation and that's actually quite a
good thing what do you mean so if you
have
um
if you borrowed
um 100 pounds yeah 100 years ago
No in fact if you brought 20 pounds 100
years ago that would have been enough
for you to pay your rent for a month
and go and go out for dinner with the
change and so like let's say you
borrowed it probably 100 years ago you
come forward today and you and your very
elderly friend you know your friends
your friend friend says actually can I
have that 20 pounds back now yeah sure
hand over 20 pounds you barely even
notice it's gone yeah so the the value
of your debt has been eroded over time
so if you even if you never actually pay
off a penny of it the amount of pounds
that you owe Remains the Same
then the actual amount that you can the
actual buying power is always being
eroded and so if you have a mortgage for
example and you and you've got a
mortgage now then 10 years later let's
say I've got a mortgage for 200k
10 years later that 200k would be worth
less yeah but I would still have to only
pay off 200k correct So based on so yeah
it's roughly half in the last 20 years
so you took out you borrowed it 20 years
ago today you owe the same number of
pounds but if you're if your value of
your asset has increased in line with
inflation if your income has increased
in line with inflation then it's so much
easier it's twice as easy for you to pay
back that mortgage as it was when you
took it out and so is that why interest
rates and mortgages are a thing in that
the bank is like hang on this money this
mortgage is going to be worth less X
number of years from now therefore we
need to
we as the borrower need to pay an
ongoing fee I guess to give the bank
something or how does that work not
really because remember the banks kind
of create the money so yeah so so and
there are there are some there are in
some it depends on how things are funded
you can't have some situation where
someone needs to see a return on it but
essentially like the the reason that we
have
um yeah the reason they have interest
rate is because then is that it's
putting a price on money and it goes
into a whole load of technical stuff
that we don't need to get into today but
when when interest rates are low you're
more likely to borrow money because it's
cheaper and when interest rates are high
you're less likely to do it because it's
costing you more
um which and this is this is how the
government kind of controls the the
money supply by setting interest rates
to make to make people more minded to
borrow and spend versus less
so if the government decrees that hey
interest rates are now zero percent
what's what's gonna happen everyone's
going to go out and borrow more money oh
because they can borrow the money
effectively for free yeah which which is
what happened for a long time yeah we
had zero rates for ages and that's why
it's one of the big reasons why um the
prices of property stock market any
anything you can think of went up
because people could people could borrow
money to go and buy assets okay and
because of supply and demand if people
are buying the things the price of the
thing is going to go up yeah exactly and
so when people have been saying oh for
the last 10 years property has been
going up and up and up and up it's a big
partly because it's actually been so
easy to get a mortgage yeah everything's
been going up because Money's been kind
of effectively free and then now that's
not the case and so that's gonna
massively change the dynamic but it's
still it's it's kind of it's still the
case that because you've always got that
this this inflation is such a core part
of everything because there's no like
you you probably know the bank of
England's Target is two percent
inflation a year same in the US
um there's no reason for that to be the
case it's just they've decided that
that's what it should be but that means
that you that that that's that's setting
a floor on it so if so if it's above it
as it is now then oh if I'm actually
restart trying to do something about
this but if it's below then it's Panic
stations we need to print a load of
money do whatever we can to get it back
to the two percent so you've always got
of inflation of effectively at least two
percent over the long term which is
making everyone poorer so that's kind of
what I mean by the system being rigged
against you and why why do they want two
percent rather than zero percent or
minus two percent it's at a two percent
for no like mathematical reason it was
just it was a suggestion that someone
made once they ended up getting taken on
but the theory of it is that deflation
is bad so if things are going to get
cheap if you know things are going to
get cheaper in the future it's not it's
I won't spend any money correct yeah if
I knew that a sailor's coming six months
from now yeah I would wait until well
six months from around to buy the next
iPhone or whatever the thing might be so
that's that's the theory and so the idea
is that's bad so if you said it at two
percent even if you undershoot a bit you
still you still above zero so so that's
good okay I personally don't buy this at
all because like think of your laptop
like laptops are always getting cheaper
you know if you wait another six months
you'll always be able to get something
better for the same money but you do it
anyway because you want the thing and if
you want to get your groceries this week
you still go and buy them because you
need to eat this week so I'm not
convinced by this whole this whole thing
about like deflation being bad but now
we've reached a point which I think is
really important point where deflation
and it would be disastrous for the
financial system because everyone
especially the government has so much
debt so
if you ended up and you kind of the idea
is if you have
inflation then and you've got a fixed
amount of debt and you have inflation
then or Everything grows relative to the
debt so everything that you could
everything that gets produced is worth
more the debt stays the same all good if
you have
um deflation then you've got the
opposite of that so the debt is
effectively growing as a proportion of
everything else which would be a
disaster with what we have now is a
situation where every where the
government has got about
um two and a half trillion pounds worth
of debt it's 100 of GDP
um and so if they're they they can't
have deflation because that means that
that debt is growing and growing and
growing as a proportion they need to
have inflation because that's the only
way to stop the debt from growing they
have to borrow more money every year
they've borrowed money in every year
except they bought they borrowed more
than they've brought in and something
like more every year but six out of the
last 50. and so there's there's nothing
you can do about it and so the the
amount that's borrowed it just goes up
every single year so the only thing that
you can do to stop that getting
completely out of control is to either
grow the economy with economic economic
growth which isn't happening because
productivity is rubbish or
um actually like just inflate the cost
of everything
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by heal I've been using hula I've
been a pain customer of huel since 2017
since my fifth year of medical school
when I first discovered it and basically
what it is if you haven't heard of it is
that it is a meal in a shake it got the
perfect balance of carbs and fiber and
proteins and fat and it contains 26
different vitamins and minerals all you
do is add water or milk to the powder
usually I use water you can shake it up
or you can blend it I prefer to blend
and then it becomes a fantastic option
if you're like me and you're kind of
busy and so you don't really have time
for breakfast or lunch my favorite
version is the heel black edition it's
absolutely sick 400 calories 40 grams of
protein for 400 calories I'm trying to
get hinge and it's actually pretty hard
to find something that has such a high
protein content for such a low calorie
trade-off and so I really like using the
heel black edition to start my mornings
off it's vegan it's gluten-free it's
lactose free the Black Edition is
available in nine flavors my favorite is
salted caramel and I wouldn't recommend
having every single meal heal because
that gets a bit annoying after a while
but it's absolutely fantastic it's like
one of the meals of the day especially
if you're busy and you're gonna kind of
default to something unhealthy otherwise
it's also very affordable so it actually
works out to one pound 68 per meal for a
400 calorie meal which is just
incredible value and actually way
cheaper than other generic protein
shakes on the market and it saves a
bunch of time because it's so quick and
easy to make and so it's particularly
exciting that they're sponsoring the
podcast and actually we had the founder
of huel Julian Hearn who was on the very
first season of the podcast that was a
sick episode that got so many rave
reviews as well anyway if you're
interested in trying out huel then head
over to huel.com forward slash Deep dive
and if you use that URL a it really
helps me out but B you also get a free
t-shirt and also a free Shaker that
comes with your order so go to heal.com
forward slash Deep dive that'll also be
linked down in the video description or
the show notes and thank you so much
heal for sponsoring this episode this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want now if
you're based in the UK you might be
familiar with the concept of an Isa
which is an individual savings account
which is basically a tax-free wrapper
that you can put money in you can put 20
000 pounds in every year up to twenty
thousand pounds and it resets every
April and then all that money can grow
and it's completely tax-free for the
rest of your life and if you want to
sign up for an iso you can sign up for
one completely for free also on trading
212. so if you haven't yet filled up
your eyes allowance or at least put some
money into your Isa for this year that
might be a good step forward also very
excitingly there's a new feature that
they've added to the app which is a
daily interest on your uninvested cash
these interest rates may go up or done
over time as the econ environment
changes but the cool thing is that you
get paid out every single day if you're
into that sort of thing the app also
lets you Auto invest which is a great
thing because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started with investing and
you want to give it a go then you can
download the app on the App Store and if
you use the coupon code Ali Ali it will
give you a totally free share worth up
to 100 pounds it's available on iPhone
and Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode why does the government need to
borrow money can't they just press a
button and print the extra 500 billion
that they need like they did in covet
um kinda yeah um they could but
um they the the risk is Runaway
inflation
which is kind of what we've got we've
got now so the the one of the big
reasons that we've got so much inflation
right now is that so much money was
created printed when we had covered
because they did just have to go and
like they had to they had to kind of
print some amount of money like it was
impossible to know what the right amount
was but I think it kind of went they
ended up going over the top so everyone
everyone kind of not everyone but a
large proportion of people came out of
covert better than they went better off
than they went in because of all this
sort of money that was sort of created
and dished out so what that so that then
creates that everyone goes and tries to
spend all that money yeah
there's no extra supply of anything so
supply and demand you end up getting
inflation so they could go um so you
can't just go absolutely nuts and go
everyone have whatever you want because
you're not creating anything extra
anything new in the real world
so there's always there's only so much
stuff that's being produced yep yeah
because I wish the shortages for like
PlayStations and stuff back in the day
chip shortages and everything so there's
a fixed Supply everyone wants a PS5 and
therefore the price goes up and up and
up the black market starts to happen
people start reselling it on eBay
and
that you're saying that that phenomenon
plays out across everything that anyone
wants to buy and therefore the price of
everything goes up exactly and we call
that inflation yeah so if you had um
like government clicks their fingers and
every single person wakes up with an
extra million pounds in the bank account
so you go fantastic I'll go buy whatever
I want but creating extra money hasn't
created any extra stuff so everyone
rushes out to spend their extra million
pounds and girls and tries to buy
everything so what happens the price of
everything has to correct upwards so to
to maintain that scarcity
okay interesting so someone listening to
this might say
why does the price have to go up isn't
isn't it just the evil shopkeeper that's
deciding to price gouge because
everyone's only got a million quid it
doesn't cost them any more to produce
the product so why are they putting the
price up
they don't have to but prices are price
is a signal that tells markets what to
do it's it's if you you could just keep
the prices as they are but then you'd
run out of everything and so like how do
you manage demand if there's more if
there's if there's only a finite amount
of stuff that can be produced then how
do you how do you kind of encourage
people to produce more of it and how do
you allocate between what you should be
producing you you that price is the
signal so if everybody suddenly wants to
go and but and buy grapes for whatever
reason the the price the the the price
of them could would go up because that's
the way of controlling the supply of
what you've got and it's a signal to get
more people to come into the market and
produce grapes it's like if you if you
if you don't if you don't have prices
there's no way of doing that so in my
million pound example there could also
be a law saying you're not allowed to
increase prices everything's the same as
it was but then just went out of
everything
so it doesn't really help there's
there's still this kind of fundamental
there there's sort of there's a
fundamental scarcity and you kind of
need
you kind of in money to be scarce as
well
because if you end up with abundant
money and scarce resources well that's
inflation
doubt okay
um
but there are some assets or some items
that the government does say you are not
allowed to increase the price of this
yeah uh like what's what's the deal with
that
that's just trying to that's basically
trying to avoid ill effects of
um
of like if you have if you have the
price of lots of items going up then it
should kind of it annoys people but it
doesn't matter if people can't get a PS5
then it's like it's not a big societal
problem but there are some but like if
the price of a certain medication goes
up then that's a really bad thing so
they try to control for that and it's
they can't they kind of have to do it
but it doesn't really help because if
the price of it did go up then in theory
that would encourage more people to come
into the market to produce that thing
yes and you'd end up with with more it's
a bit like rent controls I mean so we've
been coming to talking about property
later but with like when rents are going
up a lot then they'll go oh well the
answer is rent controls tell these
greedy landlords that they can't
increase the rent
that's sort of a solution but that just
that doesn't encourage any more property
to be
produced to be created to be brought
into the market it actually discourages
it and it doesn't produce anymore the
reason that rents go up is because
there's more Supply than there there's
more demand than there is Supply
so if you if you say well rent is now
capped at this level then all the people
who suddenly loads of people are willing
to pay that level yeah but there's no
way of allocating the housing that
you've got so loads of people end up
they don't have the option to pay more
to get something they just have nothing
okay so this is what you get in Sweden
where okay where sorry what's happening
sorry and um in um Stockholm I think it
is but they they have um they have rent
controls and so there's only a certain
you can only charge a certain amount and
see what what you end up with is it's
like impossible to find somewhere to
rent because there's just there is no
there's no extra Supply and so you end
up with like a black market of people
doing sublets and stuff like that
because they're just there's no way of
finding anywhere so that that's a that's
a property example but then it's the
same for it's the same for anything like
you cut capping the price sort of solves
a problem in the short term but it
doesn't really start in the longer term
so is it like you know people always
complain about uh Uber and their
um sort of like charge thingy surge
pricing search pricing yeah what's what
what's the deal with that yeah same
thing so the idea with that is so surge
pricing it's a way it's both a way of
allocating the the demand that there is
so like you might look at that oh I'm
just gonna walk it's not worth it so
that is a way of kind of like reducing
the demand allocating The Limited supply
of draw of cars that there is but it's
also a signal to the market to to come
and participate so I've spoken to Uber
drivers before who've said that they
when they get a notification that the
surge pricing's in effect they'll grab
their keys and go out so that's pulled
more people into the market so the price
is kind of annoying for you when you
kind of see that notification you've got
to pay more but it helps to sort out the
market
I feel like okay so people on the
political left tend to be
I I think
anti-free Market anti-capitalism
pro-government controls of stuff
what's what would be their biggest I
guess what's what's their most
compelling argument
um
for
rent control and things like that like
what what would they say
and by that I mean we because yeah well
I think
It's tricky because I think we could all
recognize
it's very easy to recognize the problem
it's very hard to actually give a
solution and like it's very you can't
it's very easy to just kind of appeal to
the market argue leave the market to its
own devices and that'll sort it out
maybe it will maybe it won't yeah but
even if it does it can still cause a lot
of pain either in the short term or
permanently for for certain groups of
people so it's very so it's really easy
to go oh you know because it's like let
rents increase because you know some
people will be willing to pay it and
those who can't will move out but then
you end up you could end up with a
situation where
um nurses just can't afford to live in
the whole of London and that's not
that's not good for anyone yeah so it's
definitely not perfect to just say oh
you know let the market do its thing for
any of these things so but then what
what you actually do about it it's hard
because normally when you start it's
when you start making an intervention
you make an intervention with the best
of intentions but then it will have some
completely unintended consequence on
something else so then you'll have to go
make another intervention to fix that
yeah and then another another and you
said you end up with a situation where
the government is trying to just like
constantly patch things over and be and
doing more and more when really to the
greatest extent possible I think you
just kind of want to leave the economy
to sort itself out because the economy
is like it's an emergent thing of all of
us as individuals doing whatever we want
to do freely transacting with whoever we
want to and so the signals that the
economy is giving it's always going to
be better than like a few people that
are Bank of England conference room oh
well I think it should be this like that
the the collective is always going to be
smarter than a few individuals so as far
as possible you want to kind of leave
things to their own devices but you just
can't do that fully
um
and I guess the issue with leaving
things to their own devices is that then
the people like nurses who are
absolutely core members of keeping a
society functioning but are not
economically incentivized to do so they
get screwed over
because I guess something like the NHS
is in almost inherently and I'm thinking
out loud here and so please correct me
if I'm wrong it is almost inherently an
anti-economic thing where the government
is like screw the prices we are going to
fund everything which is amazing which
is fantastic but it does mean that okay
okay cool state funded Healthcare System
where is that money gonna come from the
government could just keep printing more
and more of it but then you'll have
inflation and then the price of
everything goes up and people complain
alternatively the government could
borrow the money from somewhere in which
case they have to pay back at some point
alternatively the government could just
quote raise taxes on the rich in which
case why why can't we just raise taxes
on the rich like you know get the you
know 80 tax rate like get these rich
people they've got enough money anyway
landlords like me and you have too much
money on our hands we should we should
raise taxes on the rich like what's what
would be the counter to that view I
think you the the counter the the
counter that you always see from people
who don't like that idea is oh they'll
just leave
um I'm not convinced I'm sure I'm sure
like on the margin some of them will but
you'll go you'll people live in a place
for a reason that's not just tax driven
and it's very easy to say oh well I just
go and live in Portugal or something but
most people probably wouldn't so I think
you get I think you can but you do get
to a point where
um there is sort of there is only so
much tax you can you can collect before
people start going well actually I'm
just not going to bother earning anymore
because it's not worth it to me and you
can argue about where that threshold is
but there is a threshold where just go
physically it just isn't worth it
anymore and that's not a good thing
because if you assume that people are
creating economic value for people by
whatever they do then you want them to
be doing more of it and not doing less
of it so you could end up jacking the
tax rate right up it just kind of puts
everyone off doing anything so you end
up not really collecting any extra
attacks and a load of things don't get
created but where is that level
who knows and I think and I think a very
fair counter would be well there are
plenty of people who are not earning
money through their hard work they're
earning it because they've got a whole
load of assets and maybe they've got
those assets because they were passed
down to them maybe they've got those
assets because of something that they
did 20 years ago and then because of
zero interest rates everything else the
value of those assets has gone up and so
those people are not productively doing
anything so tax them and I think that
having a having a wealth tax is
something that always kind of gets
thrown out as being off too hard and
blah blah blah but at some point it's
probably going to have to be the answer
because you do you do have like like
inequality is just like absolutely
because of what happened in 2008 which
we could talk about a bit if it's
interesting you you right because of
what's happened with money inequality
has absolutely exploded and so if you do
end up with this concentration of wealth
in a small number of people then you
have to somehow sort of tax that small
number of people you have to but there
is still a limit there is still there is
still no kind of infinite amount of
money that you can just tax away from
people so everyone can have everything
but they what they're still economics is
about scarcity effectively the man how
you manage the scarce resources you've
got
hmm
okay so on this like just following this
thread on the wealth tax the idea would
be that you tax people not as a
percentage of their income but as a
percentage of their overall wealth yeah
is that is that sort of what the US does
with property taxes and things property
tax is closer to it so there's um
there's a really
um popular the popular popular among
certain economists um called land value
tax so which is a bit like a wealth tax
but specific to land so you you
basically tax the the owners of land
um because you know someone has to to
over there and they can't just pick the
you can't just pick your land off and
land up and take off another country so
it's quite easy to do and they're
they're basically lots of very good
economic reasons why this is a good
thing why this is a good thing to do
um but it's probably not going to happen
because
um many very very powerful and
influential people including most of the
House of Lords are big landowners so
it's not it's not likely to happen but
that would be that would be one form of
wealth tax another form would be you
know you kind of have to sort of send in
the value of all your with all your bank
accounts all your Isis your stocks and
shares accounts all of that you have to
sort of send it in every year and then
you get taxed a percentage of that
I'm not saying it's practically easy
it's not I'm not necessarily here saying
advocating it and saying this is the
solution I don't go there in the book
but while we're having the conversation
I think we have to recognize that there
is that inequality is going is going to
reach a point where something like that
has to happen because if you think about
it taxing income tax is just so weird
because you tax things that you don't
want people to do like smoking sure you
also tax things like
working
we can kind of do want people to do yeah
and because because you can't in a way
to kind of go and get more taxes kind of
get nervous about well you know there's
if you even if you tax the hell out of
the richest one percent that still only
gets you a certain amount so everyone
else has to pay more as well so everyone
ends up paying more more tax you end up
with like quite a lot of people you
think don't even think of as high
earners like teachers being pulled into
the like the 40 higher bracket so
everyone's taxes go up there is only so
much that you can so much you can get
so at some point you have to go well
yeah you have to find another way of
doing this or you have to say the
government has to say actually well
we're not going to provide all the
services that we're going to and so yeah
and then you get the whole like well the
government's trying to destroy the NHS
they just wanted to be privatized yeah
kind of narrative yeah exactly
man
what's interesting stuff it's really
interesting stuff like whenever I I
start even vaguely thinking about it or
talking to anyone about sort of economic
policy and things I just kind of think
man like running a country must be so
hard because there's there's no easy
answer to any of this stuff no and I
guess something even something like the
wealth tax it's like
yeah just the way that our government is
set up means that
it just so happens that the House of
Lords Lords has a lot of has a lot of
land and so it would be pretty hard to
pass a wealth tax or a land tax law
against them and like you would think
that well the House of Lords is there is
like a check and balance against the
government or something like that but
when the incentives are so aligned in
favor of I won't hold on to my money
yeah how'd you get anything done yeah
outside of I don't know a military coup
and get rid of them and stuff which
might be what some people are advocating
for yeah exactly and the key a key part
of something like a land tax is supposed
to be that you that replaces all other
taxes so if you tax that then you don't
have to tax people's earnings which kind
of makes sense I think they they're
quite right concern that a lot of people
would have is that they'd actually just
add that on top so as well as taxing you
on on you on your earnings and your
savings and your vat and this and that
and the other you'd also tax something
else which I think is a reasonable
objection but because again because it
comes back to the debt so much debt has
been built up over the last 50 years
that just covering the cost of the
interest on that debt is huge especially
now interest rates have gone up a bit
well quite a lot so we now spend as much
on just paying the interest on the debt
as we do on defense and soon we'll be
paying as much on the interest on the
debt as we do on education so if the
debt keeps growing that a higher and
higher proportion of everything of all
the tax revenue you get has to go to
Just paying your debt
okay I I still don't quite understand
why the government has to borrow money
because if the government let's say if
the UK government borrows money from the
US
surely to people in the UK that is just
the equivalent of printing more money
because they don't realize where the
money's come from and because once the
money's in the system the price of
everything goes up so why is the
government trying to borrow money at all
from like hey where does the government
borrow money from and then why do they
borrow bother borrowing it rather than
just printing it yeah so they borrow
money from
um all sorts of all sorts of places
including so like if people have um
bonds as an investment bonds probably
something you've got most people have
heard of but I really think too much
about what it is but that's basically
lending money to the government and also
lots of people have those in their
pensions
um lots of people
um in other countries have those those
as Investments lots of countries have
those so like China is a massive owner
of U.S debt and so you borrow from other
countries other individuals things like
that
um that's where it comes from
um
as an alternative you could just create
it but then you end up you you sort of
have the but then you have the inflation
problem like you've you have to you
you've and inflation kind of ends up
being a bit being like a tax anyway so
basically you end up ultimately paying
one way or the other but if you're I I
get why you wouldn't have inflation if
you're borrowing from people in the UK
as part of the Pension funds or whatever
but if you're borrowing from borrowing
from China
where like that's essentially free money
that's coming into the system
somewhat uh somewhat without a link to
the UK so why is borrowing from China
any different to pressing the print
money button
um it's different because if you're
borrowing money from another country
you're having to pay out interest ah to
the other country okay which you're then
having to pay so that's costing you
so some proportion of the taxes you
collect Go to paying them back okay
whereas if you just printed it you won't
have to pay back and then sort of you
end up with more money in circulation
yeah exactly so by borrowing money from
China you end up with some more money in
circulation but but by the fact but the
fact that you have to pay it back means
it's not as much as if you were to just
print the money yeah that's right
essentially there is no there's no kind
of magical answer to the fact that there
is only a that there is there's only
there's a scarce amount of human effort
human effort and it's kind of the
limiting factor and so when you have
productivity improvements so like you
have you have ai means that everyone can
now do more with less well that's great
that means that that's great
productivity it means that are now we
can now produce more the same amount of
people working for the same amount of
time can produce more
um more stuff yep which means which
means you can then support a greater
amount of money you kind of need a
greater amount of money to represent
that greater amount of stuff yeah okay
but they always have to be there has to
be some kind of balance so if you you
just you if you kind of went and like
trebled the amount of money without
growing the amount of stuff and that's
where you have problems okay so this is
why everyone cares about like country
productivity yeah and stuff yeah because
if if so if hypothetically we could just
wave a magic wand and Magic up a house
out of nowhere would that basically
solve the housing crisis
I guess it works I mean the the reason
that that productivity is important is
because it's about it's about this
limiting factor yeah the amount of of
stuff humans can create is is the limit
so raising that limit is is a good thing
it makes it easy it makes it easier for
people to I mean everyone can get what
they want with less effort yeah which is
what everyone ultimately wants so it's
like when when the tracker gets invented
in invented Suddenly It's people are
less likely to starve yeah because it's
easier to make food yeah so similarly if
you could wear the magic one and create
a house people would be less likely to
be homeless because it's just easy to
create houses yeah and then you're
captured by the amount of land you have
physically on Earth rather than the
amount of
Builders and property developers you
have willing to build houses yeah and so
something like AI is effectively like a
magic wand for certain industries
unfortunately it's not yet a magic one
for something like building a house but
a tractor would have been a magic one
for growing growing and harvesting stuff
yeah exactly so it's kind of it's good
news all around and so if it means that
you know if you use it in medicine and
so doctors can now sort of like I don't
know diagnose things more more quickly
also more of their time doing the things
that they really need to be doing rather
than sort of messing around with things
that they don't then that means that
there's more output per hour works for
them and so that's what so that's that's
what you ultimately want and that's and
that's the only way to kind of the only
way to kind of keep the party going and
keep giving giving people more and more
and more is to find ways of producing
more the shortcut to doing that is to
create more money if you if you if you
if you if you print more money then you
and you dish it out to people and you
give them everything they want today a
then great but really you're just kind
of borrowing from the future in a way
you're kind of you're papering over the
facts that you you're pretending
everyone can have what they want but in
reality they can't
damn
I don't think I've ever quite understood
that before because I guess like if I
think of my business it makes a lot of
sense I'm very keen on for example my
team using AI for stuff because if we
can do twice the amount of work in half
the time yeah suddenly it means we can
produce more stuff if we produce more
stuff it means we can sell more stuff
which means we make more money
uh if we make more money it means that I
get richer but it also means we can then
hire more people to do more things and
it's like this pursuit of more and more
and more and eventually if we assume
that the job of my business is to create
videos and podcasts like this one that
people can listen to that will help them
build a life they love generally
everyone benefits When a particular
business grows yeah and so similarly if
you're running a hospital and suddenly
your doctors and nurses and everything
twice as efficient or you had twices or
the medication I guess was half the
price because there was it was easy to
wave a magic one and produce it everyone
benefits from the growth of the hospital
business as it were yeah exactly and
that's the the wonderful thing about
technology if because if you can if you
can like 3D print a house and so it's
quicker and easier to do that if you
could use AI in your job and so you now
own you can now get it done in half the
time and spend the other half the time
doing something else that's valuable or
even just relax instead because that's a
valuable thing then that's great and so
technology is is amazing because it it
allows you to do more with less
and so but then you've got this kind of
weird tension that that's
that that's deflationary but because if
you're doing more with if you're doing
more with less if everyone kind of gets
their job done in half the time then
sits around then that's kind of
deflationary because you you need less
money but that's kind of a side point
the way we don't need to go we talked
about the deflationary is not inherently
bad it's only bad if you have lots of
debt absolutely and therefore the
government thinks really bad because
they have a lot of debt that's it yeah
so yeah you kind of got this kind of
perverse situation like we've ended up
like I've said say in the book that
we're coming we're like 50 years into a
financial experiment where it kind of it
has to come to an end you can't just
keep growing debt forever and ever and
ever and ever and ever there comes a
point where it's just it just doesn't
work anymore if you if you could if you
could have a completely painless reset
where everyone just kind of goes back to
the beginning and starts again on on a
different grounding then you'd be kind
of welcoming things getting cheaper and
because well why not why wouldn't you so
what's stopping us from having a reset
historically it's just it when systems
change fake sort of change messily and
it turns out to be not great for for
anyone so like on on the site on the
other side of of for everyone who has
borrowed money There's A lender and so
if you suddenly go actually guys you
know what we're just going to wipe out
all debt and this is something that used
to happen quite a lot like in the in the
in biblical times though that jubilees
were every so many years if you go and
wipe out all the debts yeah
um and if so if you did that it would
kind of be well in a way great but also
you'll basically end up saying to all
these people who loaned you money sorry
you're out of luck and so I don't know I
don't know what the ramifications of it
would be but it would probably not be
very pretty it's also associated with um
changes of of power so if you end up
like with the US kind of like not being
the dominant country
um the dollar underpinning everything
anymore and he ends up with China or
somewhere else having that power instead
then it's probably going to be messy so
you kind of at some point you're going
to end up with some kind of either a
hard reset or a soft reset of the whole
system but no one knows what it's when
it's gonna happen or what it's going to
look like this episode is very kindly
brought to you by Shopify now Shopify is
great we've been using Shopify for the
last several years to power the
e-commerce side of our business when
selling our planners and we're also
using it to power the back end of the
e-commerce section of a tech brand that
we're in the process of building out
more details to come on that in a while
but Shopify is sick it's basically an
all-in-one Commerce platform that you
can use to sell pretty much anything
online or in person or through social
media platforms and it's great it's an
all-in-one platform that lets you build
and grow and manage every aspect of the
process from literally zero to powering
like billions of dollars of Revenue it's
super easy to get started you don't need
to learn how to code they've got a bunch
of really like nicely designed templates
that will make any e-commerce site just
look absolutely sick and they power more
entrepreneurs than anyone else so there
are millions of businesses in the world
across 175 countries that use Shopify to
be able to sell stuff and so if you're
interested in potentially starting a
business or growing a business then I'd
highly recommend using Shopify like I
said it's what we use to sell our stuff
on the internet It's amazing And even
companies like gymshark that are doing
like one billion plus dollars in Revenue
are being powered by Shopify so like you
know that you have a lot of room to grow
on the platform anyway if you want to
give it a go and sign up for a totally
free trial to see if you like it then
head over to shopify.com forward slash
deep dive and that URL will be linked
down in the video description and also
in the show notes and thank you so much
Shopify for sponsoring this episode so
is the stuff that we've talked about so
far basically a reasonable a reasonable
starting point as to why the financial
system is rigged against you and me and
the people listening to this podcast
so I think if we can kind of say like
the core the core thing that is
important to understand and why you
could say it's rigged against you
is this point about
um the rate of inflation being higher
than the rate of interest so if you if
you're guaranteed to lose buying power
by saving money then that's not good and
so that I think that that's that's
probably the most important thing to
understand so okay well it's that way
it's been that way for 15 years why is
it going to continue being that way well
that's because of what we've just been
talking about so you have to you can't
have interest rates being too high
because everyone's got so much debt so
if you if you jacked interest rates up
to 15 then it would bankrupt everyone
including the government so the
government's own borrowing costs have
gone up so much because of the Rises
interest rates we've had even over the
last year if they went up too much
further then you end up with basically
all your tax revenue goes to paying back
the debt and there's none left over for
anything else so you can't have interest
rates going too high
but you also need to have a pretty
decent amount of inflation because
there's actually lots of good reasons
why you'd have inflation anyway to do
the globalization but even if you put
that aside well why would the government
want there to be inflation well because
that's how they effectively shrink the
value of their ever-growing debt pile
and so you they don't want it to be as
high as it is now because it gets heavy
it makes everyone very unhappy but if
you could sort of have like four four or
five percent inflation forever or look
for at least like the next five ten
years I think it would probably be quite
happy with that so that's why I believe
that we've kind of come out of this era
of very low interest rates very low
inflation I'm going into an era of
having
um much higher higher inflation higher
interest rates but crucially the rate of
inflation is higher than the rate of
interest and it is the government who
pulls the lever on the interest rate
and then inflation is a thing that just
happens yeah and it's the it's the the
bank of England that supposedly
independently sets
um interest rates but supposedly yeah I
mean it's it's it's a brunt it's a
branch it's a branch of government it
technically has Independence for the
purposes of setting rates but if you
just look at human incentives I just
don't believe it at all and it's like in
theory they they can decide how much to
borrow and they just happened to just oh
and how much to and how much money to
print for the bank of England can decide
how much money wants to print it in
2020. it just so happened to decide to
print the exact amount that the
government needed to cover its own
spending plans but it needed to borrow
money for covert so I'm not convinced by
the independence oh interesting Okay
cool so at this point
we agree that we've understood a bit
about money we agree that the financial
system is rigged against us
um in the book you talk about a few
different principles as to how normal
people can make money work for them yeah
and can prosper in this potentially well
in this very rigged Financial system
yeah so I wonder if we can go go through
some of those okay
um and so principle principle number one
forget about growing your wealth with
savings yes what does that mean so it's
not saying don't save so you need to
have an emergency fund that's cash you
if you're saving up for something like a
house deposit then you need to have that
as savings not expose it to the markets
where Anything could happen so nothing
don't say and of course you have to save
because that's the precursor to
investing you have to save money before
you can invest it but saving you can't
just save because as we've just covered
you'll you'll even if you're you've got
you've got your money in the best
possible bank account that's paying you
the biggest amount of Interest you're
still earning less than the rate of
inflation so you're losing buying power
so it's better to it's better to save
than not to save but you then need to
cut you need to go and do something with
it because it's it's crazy it should be
the case that you you can just save your
money and you'll earn a return on it so
without taking any kind of crazy risks
you end up doing quite well but
unfortunately that's not the case and
that's not the case because the rate of
interest is lower than the rate of
inflation yeah but if it if it were
identical to the rate of inflation then
we'd all be happy we'd be happier if if
if if it was it was higher that'd be
even better so so by the time the
government has to pay more often
interest rates to that all the debt that
they've got and the government has all
this debt and therefore the government's
unhappy yes
and also anyone who's ever borrowed
money is unhappy because the mortgage
rates are going up and then maybe they
can't afford the mortgage and the house
gets repossessed so some people are
happy and are unhappy regardless of
which side of this interest inflation
rate kind of equation we're on pretty
much yeah what mistakes do people make
when it comes to saving
um
I think for kind of let's say people of
30 and younger they probably kind of got
a more realistic idea of savings because
they've grown up with until the last
couple of years your savings just don't
do anything for you you can see it's
like literally like 0.1 and so you kind
of know that I think for the older
generation because for most of History
you have been rewarded for saving
because all of this stuff isn't
relatively new phenomenon
um you they're probably more likely to
keep on like using cash Isis and things
like that and just kind of keeping a lot
in cash because they see it seems like
that well you know it's a good thing to
do but that's because they're not
they're just kind of they're not
factoring in inflation so like it's
called like in like I've heard it's
another economic terms like real terms
so if something's in real terms it's
like you have to you've deduct the
effects of inflation so if you look so
if you look at it the amount great I'm
making three percent in my bank account
that's wonderful but if you look at it
in real terms after deducting inflation
it could be minus four percent so that's
kind of a mistake that people make a
kind of a general level but people it's
hard to say what is a mistake because
everyone I've said at the very beginning
everyone's weird about money and like
you can like there are lots of people
who are
very wealthy who keep loads of money in
cash and you could say well that's a
mistake because if you were investing
this then you'd be able to do even
better but if it makes you feel
comfortable and relaxed and happy that
it's not a mistake is it yeah that was
one of my biggest takeaways from Morgan
Hazel's book the psychology of money
around how what is rational is not
always what is reasonable and previously
I used to say that like oh I would never
pay for mortgage because I can get a
better return in the s p which may be
true and maybe rational but
paying off a mortgage helps me sleep at
night yeah so like you know what am I
really optimizing for here absolutely
yeah there's there's a really good
episode of um I think it was
Freakonomics podcast where there's like
some research about like what economists
think that we should be doing what about
make decisions we should be making out
money things like savings and paying off
mortgages and The Economist getting very
upset because it's not what people
actually do in reality so what's the
point of saying what people should do if
people actually feel completely
differently
um do you have any rules or principles
that are helpful um for you and for
maybe people that you would advise uh
around saving money each month
um
I think it's very personal
um something that I really believe in is
um intentional spending
so obviously you can't some people can
be in situations where you really need
to save the absolute maximum you
possibly can for some possible reason
but I think even if you're not in that
situation then you don't have to like
deny yourself everything but you but
it's very easy to fall into just
spending money for the sake of it not
barely even noticing it so you're you're
doing it to impress someone you're doing
it because you thought it would you kind
of you did make you happy once but now
it doesn't or you didn't you don't
really think about it it's very easy to
just kind of spend money without kind of
thinking about what makes you happy so
I'm a big proponent of
um intentional spending so just so spend
money on whatever makes you happy and
just be conscious of what you're
spending so rather so obviously there
can be situations where having a budget
is helpful but rather than having a
budget I think it can be a good idea to
just write down everything that you
spend so don't don't give yourself a
limit but just everybody rule is every
time you spend money you have to write
it down and you have to physically like
write it down I can do it in your notes
app or whatever but just don't if you're
back if you go I can go into my bank and
see that that's different you need to
actually be doing it because then in the
moment it's kind of making you think huh
do I really want to do this do will I
want to write this down in two minutes
time so it's quite a good way of kind of
making making yourself question every
spending decision you make without going
into budgeting which I think can be can
be really useful but it can also be too
rigid
yeah it's almost like uh you know I've
had I've had a bunch of experience with
tracking your calories and macros yeah
to try and get gains and even just when
I write down how much protein I'm taking
and I'm like oh
this is radically different to sort of
just having a mental model of of like a
guesstimate of how much protein I'm
taking in yeah which is radically
different to not thinking about it at
all it's exactly the same thing and if
you're and if you're if you're on a
custom you're trying to cut calories and
just just knowing you have to track it
if there's like like am I going to feel
good about myself if I have to go and
put this into my app in five minutes
time it means you're less likely to do
it yeah it's that thing around um you
know there was that study that
some like weight loss experiment where
half the group did nothing and the other
half the group just weighed themselves
every day and the group that weighed
themselves every day just like lost lost
weight by default just because being
aware of a number even if you take no
active action to reduce that number
you know awareness is the first step and
then you subconsciously start changing
your behavior yeah it's so true and so I
bet if you if you were writing I bet if
you just like wrote down your word count
every day then then the same the same
thing would apply
okay nice um principle number two you
say is take on debt responsibly what do
you mean by that
um some people might be thinking all
debt is bad yeah debt is a terrible
thing you want to be debt free as soon
as possible etc etc so caveat city
um the debt is a tool it's a powerful
tool um you don't want to mess around
with power tools if so if you if you're
in a valuable vulnerable situation or
you don't know how to use it as a tool
then you can just stay away from it
um if you want to not have any debt
because that makes you feel more
comfortable then that's fine too
um all that is fine but if you want to
use debt then it can be a powerful tool
because of exactly what we're talking
about earlier you kind of you get the
other side of this Dynamic your the
inflation is reducing the amount of your
debt faster than the then you're having
to pay interest on it oh interesting so
even though the interest rates are high
right now and I feel the sting of the
mortgage payments because I'm like
bloody hell this has gone up way more
I'm actually getting a good deal because
inflation is higher than that interest
especially even though it doesn't feel
like it because I can't feel the effect
of inflation as much as I can feel the
monthly extra 600 Quid that's
disappeared yes to my interest rate on
my mortgage exactly that's it so it's
definitely not as straightforward as it
was so like when you had zero interest
rates then it says oh we'll just go and
that's like why not like about if you
could if you could lock in that low rate
forever then it was like well you'd just
be rational to just go and borrow as
much as he possibly can so people did
um but now it's like obviously more
complex than that but yeah you're
exactly right it's the same like
inflation is doing you a favor every day
you don't you don't see it you see the
interest payments that you're making out
but you don't you don't kind of see the
the effect of which the real value of
your debt is being paid down for you by
inflation so and it aligns you with the
government so like the government's
borrowing more money than anyone else
they benefit from it so watching you
interesting
um yeah I guess one thing that that's
really surprised me about the US when I
watched personal finance U.S YouTubers
you can lock in an interest rate for 30
years on a mortgage yeah whereas here
it's like five years if you're lucky and
I'm like damn I wish I'd looked at in
for five years like three years ago I
know yeah how can they just do that for
30 years and why can't we do that in the
UK I don't know I think it's it's but I
think it's because of the way everything
ends up getting insured by the
government ultimately I don't know how
it all works but there is a reason why
they're allowed to because I because if
you think about it the bank is taking on
a huge amount of risk like if because
they they happen to give this to you for
all this time they don't know what's
going to happen in the future but if
there's some way that which it all works
itself out
um but yes sadly we can't do that so
when interest rates were low I was
trying to lock everything in for as long
as I possibly could and I was like and
like there aren't that many like 10-year
kind of products around tens as far as
you go but even if it meant I was paying
more I'd go and lock everything for 10
years if I could because it's like well
it could go down a bit but it could also
go up a lot so it's symmetric so the
Ultimate model that I didn't have
because I've only ever lived in a time
of zero percent interest rates and so
when I got like a 1.5 for two years or
two percent four or five years I was
like oh come on obviously I'm only gonna
I'm gonna go for 1.5 for two years
because I get optionality and then I can
exit the mortgage two years from now and
1.5 is less than two exactly and now I'm
like tap yeah yeah we had all these
people kind of like um calling in to ask
us questions on our podcast and we're
like when interest rate when you could
borrow for like less than two percent
and go oh what do you think should I
lock in like rates could go down a bit
they could go down could get out of it
but also are you not happy with this
rate just like log it in as long as you
can nice yeah I should have uh called
according a question for a podcast
um
what are the different types of debt and
are some better than others yeah so
um Mortgage Debt is pretty much the best
type of debt you can have like best I
mean obviously a lot of people don't
want to have doubt on their own home but
the great the good thing about it is you
get it's relatively cheap you can borrow
a lot you can borrow a lot of it because
it's about the against the value of the
asset so if it's you're looking at
investing in property you can normally
borrow up to like 75 of the asset and
because the asset is expensive it means
you can borrow a lot of money quite
cheaply and
they're not going to it would a lot of
really bad stuff would need to happen
for them to suddenly ask for it back and
so if you up with the property Market
tends to not go through massive swings
and it certainly doesn't on a day-to-day
week-to-week level whereas you can
borrow against your stock market
portfolio but that could go down
like multiple percent in a day at which
point they'd go oh actually you breach
this limit now we want it back so
without a margin call yeah exactly ah
okay right that makes sense
um so you so so that so prop so Mortgage
Debt is pretty much the best type there
is
um other types of debts are borrowing
against yeah assets like your stocks not
a good idea for most people like very
very dangerous
um things like I don't know like student
debt or whatever like can still it's not
something to use as a financial tool in
terms of like going and investing
probably but can still be a good thing
to do because you're it allows you to
gain future earning power so you're
basically investing in your future
ability to earn more money yourself in
theory yes yeah it doesn't always work
that way
um and like quite credit card debt or
whatever like generally the interest
payment is so high that whatever you did
with it would have to have such a
ludicrous payoff that it's just not
going to happen
okay I have more questions about the
mortgage thing but we'll come to that
when we talk about the property stuff
cool
um principle number three avoid fixed
income Investments uh what is a fixed
income investment and why is it bad
um so the the main type of fixed income
interestment is bonds which talked about
which is effectively either which is
lending money to either the government
or a big company
um the reason this so you'll you'll lend
a certain amount of money for a certain
amount of time and you'll start making a
loan to a friend effective effectively
if you'll mean enough charge of Interest
so I'll lend you money for this period
of time you'll give me my money back in
10 years and every year you'll pay me
three percent or whatever it is
um the problem with that is that the
income is fixed so you so even if
um if you're not only might what you're
receiving not be enough to keep up with
inflation but also the money that you
get back in 10 years time is going to be
worth less than it is today so you'll
get it you're you're guaranteed you're
kind of guaranteed to lose money on your
principal over time yeah isn't this what
happened with like Silicon Valley Bank
or something they put like 75 of their
like cash into 10-year bonds like the
day before the government announced
interest rates were going through the
roof or something absurd everyone's like
oh my God yeah that's a that's a
different thing so like what I was just
just talking about is that if you if you
hold a bond all the way through to when
you eventually get it paid back you know
you know you're going to receive back
the same amount of pounds or dollars
that you gave but they're gonna be worth
less because of inflation
um but what often happens is you invest
in bond funds
um which means that
um well that's Park then take an example
of the Silicon Valley Bank which is
easier so they they were in a situation
where they might not have been able to
hold it for the full 10 years because
people if people come back and ask for
that money back they need to sell that
that 10-year bond early and for because
without going into the
mechanics are Bond pricing which is
really tedious you you end up where the
you actually might have to sell it for
less than its face value so you end so
they ended up in a situation where if
they've been able to hold it for the
entire time no problem but um they
couldn't do that and so it's value fell
so yeah but then but from the but from
the perspective of the book you know my
kind of issue with it is like well yeah
you kind of if if this if if inflation
in the future ends up being higher than
you think it's going to be then this is
not the best idea
and I should say as well lots of people
disagree with this like financial
advisors will tell you about the
importance of Bonzer I'm not a financial
advisor so yeah because the first
advisors are like oh you know the bonds
are like the ones that you can trust
because you can trust the government and
it's safer when you do the risk adjusted
stuff yeah stocks equals risky and bonds
equal safe yeah we just agree with that
assessment but it's sort of true but
then the the idea is that they're meant
to do do like move in opposite
directions and so they kind of balance
each other out and so Universal like if
the if the stock market's doing really
badly then bonds people should move
money into bonds and said bonds should
do better so it kind of balances you out
last year that did not work at all it
was the worst year for a diversified
portfolio like that since like ever and
I think that the mechanics of how things
work are fundament have fundamentally
changed so now that's not necessarily
going to be the case anymore so you just
end up with like yeah bonds are just
like bonds don't perform socks don't
perform nothing performs it's not it's
not good principle number four invest in
real assets talk to me about that yeah
so real assets basically means stuff
that you can touch
um which is property
um also like infrastructure like
government building stuff
um commodity gold oil I don't want to
touch oil um things like that things
that work like real actual stuff invest
in gold
um I'm not saying that you should invest
in all Commodities but Gold's actually
really interesting but as a gen but as a
general kind of principle around real
assets it's just like when if things if
they tend to do well when there's
inflation it's a very general rule
because it's stuff that people want and
need and it's like real so people can
choose not to buy something else but you
can't really choose not to buy any of
this stuff
um and it's um if we're going to go into
a more troubled times as we might be as
we kind of get to the end of this
financial experiment then or owning
actual real stuff that people need is a
pretty good idea and gold is kind of a
special case because it's like it's got
real world uses but it's mostly an
investment asset but I guess if we look
at the price of I mean I've never looked
at the price of gold very much I think I
did one time because my mom was like why
don't you invest in gold and I was like
surely it's not going to outperform the
s p and it didn't I was like okay cool
yeah but that's the extent of my
knowledge about gold would you recommend
normal and normal people buy gold as an
asset class
it depends it's so difficult to benefit
for any of this stuff it all depends on
your objectives all I can talk about is
what I do which is that I have
a small allocation of gold because it's
an it's an inflation hedge so broadly
you expect gold again because gold is
something real you expect gold to keep
up with inflation over time and so at
least if what you could at least you're
not kind of losing money by keeping gold
but you wouldn't want to have everything
in Gold probably unless you believe in
the imminent collapse of everything
because you're it's not going to
suddenly grow in the same way that the
stock market does yeah and how liquid is
gold as it were it's um it's very it's
pretty much one of the most liquid
markets in the world okay and so when
you invest in gold or do you do you oh
physically own gold bars or is it like
buygold.com or whatever the thing I
don't because I wish I think it would be
cool but I know
um um so there's loads of different ways
of getting exposures to Gold including
kind of like
gold funds where it's going to
financialize but what I do is I own
physical gold but it's basic but it's in
basically you buy it through a company
and it's all like in a vault so I've got
one big Vault with a whole of gold and
then they can sort of like say well Ali
then your bar is this one like you've
got this amount of it so if you ask them
to post it to you they actually would ah
so um but in reality you don't want to
do that you just want to own the thing
but have someone else have all the
hassle of looking after it nice that
sounds handy
um okay
well we're going to talk more about the
the property stuff in a little bit
because that's um I think a big big
discussion about the principle number
five invest in the stock market boringly
what do you mean by Boring win a couple
of different things about that so one is
um mostly not stock picking because for
most people stop trying to pick in
visual stocks is a really bad idea it's
a highly skilled skilled thing that most
professionals can't do so why would you
be able to do it
um and even if you could you could
probably make a better return by going
and spending your time doing something
else to earn money so most people
shouldn't be having the exciting time of
picking stocks
um also boring in terms of the type of
company you invest in so this is kind of
this has kind of happened now since the
book was written but when I wrote it it
was like you had like companies like
your Netflix and Tesla and everything
else well flying high because it's all
very exciting and everyone wants to
invest in these companies and when money
is cheap or free this is fine it's like
making profits one day is absolutely
fine they're like well this is great
it's growing fast but then when the
environment changes and you have um more
and you have higher interest rates like
we do now suddenly so I'm actually
making profit today sounds pretty good
maybe we should have companies that do
that and so so companies that are like
like called value stocks start doing
better as people are more interested in
boring companies like Consumer Staples
things that people actually need it's
not they're not going to suddenly tedx
in value and start selling loads more
stuff but it's just boring and
predictable so that's kind of that's
kind of happened now to a large extent
but I think that's going to keep on
happening because having it's profit
like money now is going to continue to
look attractive compared to what we had
in the past where it's just like as the
growth is fun and as long as you make
money one day it's all good yeah I as as
you said that it reminded me of just
something something I've been thinking
about recently which is when building a
YouTube channel and a business around
this sort of thing
historical advice has always been about
grow now worry about making or worry
about making money later yeah and that's
always been the advice I've given to
people like don't worry about
monetization unless you physically have
to you know grow the audience for two
years give value away for free Etc et
cetera Etc and then when you press the
monetization button and you raise a
course or a book or whatever the thing
might be suddenly you'll have all these
people who know like and trust you and
you'll have a torrent of people waiting
to buy your product yeah
but
um I gave a keynote last week when I was
in Austin Texas uh to a bunch of like
beginner YouTubers that we have in our
course and I found myself saying that
you know what actually if I were
building a YouTube channel today I would
really focus on profitability I'd really
focus on monetization not quite from day
one but maybe day like 91 once I've made
my first 12 20 50 videos
however many might be just like really
thinking about the business model of it
because even in that Creator economy
thing like
you work you we these days you have to
work so hard to get views it's not like
back in the day where once you grew
subscribers you could basically
guarantee a certain number of views now
every video just has to be good yeah and
if you're going to work for the views
anyway you may as well try and get the
money from it now because you that there
actually is no guarantee that that money
will come later yeah uh so I'm all about
like building the money trees and the
the monetization routes right now rather
than worrying about it for later yeah
well it makes a lot of sense to it makes
sense to kind of give give away more
than anyone else kind of how we built
our business and it's kind of like do
like deferring gratification I suppose
and and that it makes a ton of sense but
then you also need to know I suppose to
validate that there is a business there
and that you will be able to do
something with it and also like I
suppose you can you could end up having
a whole audience of people who just
expect things for free then you ask them
to pay for anything this is outrageous
how can you possibly do as you sell out
yeah there are a bunch of YouTubers that
have fallen into that sort of I guess
trap where they've sold something the
audience has responded very very
negatively and they're like oh my God
because I guess people already have
weird thoughts about selling yeah it's
already like a hard enough thing that
when you get the backlash which is what
you feared all along Suddenly It's like
oh my God I knew it was a bad idea to
sell any product on the Internet
definitely yeah um definitely want to
ask you more about the business thing uh
shortly so okay so but we've so we've
talked about investing in the show in
the stock market boringly
um we have a couple of questions from
the audience in our deeper diver
community on telegram
um so I'll just give you throw throw a
couple of those at you and then we'll
have to talk about property let's do it
so a question from uh cleanthi says what
are some habits that cost people the
most financially
I'm going to take a slightly different
way into this to answer it because I
think most of it's obvious like there's
like there's there's all sort of people
who are a lot of it comes back to like
conscious conscious spending and things
like that and so like you could people
do everyone you do what I do it everyone
does it to some degree you like spend
the money on things that they don't need
to and there's no kind of universal
version of that
um what you but and the answer's
different for everyone so like what you
should do is spend very little on your
home like if you you want to get your
housing costs as low as you possibly can
because that's your probably your
biggest cost for most people so you want
to get as low as possible I don't do
that at all because I have young kids I
spend a lot of time at home I want to
live in a really nice place and I want
to live somewhere super convenient so I
spend a lot of money on my housing so to
other people that would be the wrong
thing to do but it's the right thing for
me so I think it's very hard to have
like kind of general rules around all
this stuff but I do think that what a
lot of people do is probably around more
on the earning side
so people
the answer to basically everything is to
earn more
like just like investing in earning like
ridiculously high returns from from your
Investments is really hard and very few
people can do it consistently and the
reason you've heard of the people who
can like Warren Buffett is because there
aren't many of them so you can earn like
a certain amount of return over return
but you're like pushing that boundaries
hard there's only so much you can save
yeah you can cut to the Bone but you
can't say Beyond zero so it's like
there's only so much so what the
variable you're left with is earning and
so the spending more time thinking about
earning is the best thing that people
can do and that can be a a side business
a Creator business or that kind of thing
it could also be just be having more
intentional approach to your career like
you grew like you could you kind of if
you really like entreated your career as
a kind of like you do type you you are
the product you're taking your self
really seriously then you probably
should be job hopping and kind of trying
to sort of like apply for new jobs
frequently and move up and because
that's how you earn more and if I'm
taking a strategic approach to your
career I think probably people spend too
much time thinking about like the
investing in the saving parts and not
enough time on the earning part
I totally agree I think that's a
fantastic fantastic Point
um any advice Beyond job hopping for
people who are like oh hello I guess I
you know I'm listening to this and I
haven't really thought about my career
as it's or sort of my earning power as
its own like financial asset um yeah
anything else you would advise people on
that point what you just said is so
important like do see like your earning
power is especially when you're young is
the best financial asset you can ever
have like there is you can you can
generate uh potentially like infinite
amounts of wealth from your own earning
power most of us don't but you can't but
you can and they they the younger you
are obviously the more years you've got
to do that and also the more time you've
got to develop skills that will allow
you to do that so I think really really
thinking about how to maximize your own
earning power is what people should be
doing so like if you if you're 24 years
old and you've got you've got like 10
000 pounds to invest then it's a really
bad idea to be spending a really long
time thinking about how to how can I
invest this ten thousand pounds to
maximize my return on it because even if
you outperform the market by 10 it's
still not much in the scheme of things
CBC should really be thinking about how
can I grow my how can I grow my value
because like ultimately like you what
you earn is kind of a multiple of how
you how much value you create and how
many people you can reach to create that
value for so I suppose the economics of
it with a YouTube channel is you reach a
large amount of people but you only get
like a small amount for per per view or
whatever but then you've got a course so
you're creating a larger amount of value
for a smaller number of people but it's
like but that's the kind of way to be
thinking about it and so there's and
ultimately
so you can do it you can do it in a job
by oh okay well like what's the how can
I grow the skills that are going to make
me super valuable in this role that I'm
in now and so and then kind of go and
play that company off against others to
go and like maximize my worth what
skills are going to be it's like the
most valuable in the future maybe at the
moment it's things around AI building
your knowledge there but it could be
well how can I go how can I reach more
people and so like an employer is like a
monopoly buyer of your time and so you
like well how can I go and do something
create a business or could do something
that will allow me to go and reach
create value for a large number of
people so it's all that sort of stuff
and there's so many different ways of
doing it but kind of the ultimately it
comes down to leveraging some form or
another try and find finding a way to be
to reach a large number of people
whether that's through media or through
a business whatever else
just learned to be super like incredibly
insanely valuable for one particular
employer or whatever so they just have
to pay you for sure yeah that's the
thing I think
this is something that I've really
started to appreciate as I now own a
business and employ people just that
like
I think in the past though and and
certainly the way I see some like a lot
of people I know think about salaries is
like you know like wages almost where
it's like oh you know my employer is
doing me a disservice by not increasing
my wages and you know I'm gonna kind of
get my act together and ask for a raise
but they've they've said they don't want
to give me a raise
and it's like fundamentally if you
provide value then you then they're
they're almost forced to pay you for
that value outside of certain like
controlled Industries where as a nurse
and as a doctor there's a limit to how
much value you can provide within the
system of the NHS yeah but with outside
of the system of the NHS there is an
unlimited amount of value you could
potentially provide and so one of one of
my team members was was asking the other
day oh you know we were having a
conversation and I said you know uh
we're talking about some some issues
that she's having and and stuff and I
said you know if if we could wave a
magic wand what would solve some of
these issues and she sort of jokingly
said well if you doubled my salary we
would solve a lot of these issues and I
said okay I get that was a joke but
let's think about it what would it take
for me to double to to
what would it take for me to consider
doubling a salary and
she just never thought in that way
before she was like oh I guess in in her
mental model is like a salary is like a
thing it's a fixed thing it's not a
completely made up arbitrary thing that
a business owner or an employer just
decides it's like it's fixed and you
know the way you campaign for a salary
increases you follow the steps and you
ask the right questions and stuff
fundamentally I was I was saying look if
if you added an extra 500k value to the
business of course I'm going to pay you
an extra 100K like it's just a no-brader
so let's figure out the way you can add
500k value or if you do that inside your
own business
or a side hustle or something you get
all 500k of the value whereas I I just
think people don't really think in those
terms no I completely agree and I think
that's that's that that's where people
are costing themselves I think the
question was like the mistakes people
making that that's it it's like not
thinking in those kind of terms because
you do just it must come from from
school and from uni and everything else
you kind of you do just do you see your
salary as something that is a fixed
thing but it you you have to be the one
to you have to be the one to change it
because you as an employer you're not
going to suddenly offer to double the
salary of any of your team members like
you might offer them a raise but you're
just not gonna you're not gonna do that
why would you but it's down to them to
make that to make that happen in the
same way as if you want to earn more
money as the business owner you have to
find a way of going and creating more
value for for more people no one's going
to just pay you more for fun yeah
exactly
um okay next question from Nacho Martin
who says what is the most effective way
in your opinion to manage finances as a
cup couple
um
I think it really helps if you are
aligned to start with because sit back
at the very beginning like you're gonna
be like money blueprints from your
parents and it kind of it's all it's all
very ingrained that I think if you if
you grew up with a certain attitude
around money and sort of things about if
you've got to grow up with an attitude
that money is evil or people put the
money bad or if you grow up with like
you like you're you really have very
very little and so even when you've got
a lot it's hard to realize that you've
got a lot and that's hard to change so
if you're entering into a serious
relationship with someone I wouldn't do
this on date number one or two
um but have but having that alignment is
really important
so that's the first thing pick the right
person but once you're beyond that I
think the best thing that you can do is
talk about it and not talk about it in
terms of like people talk about like
having a having like a money date every
month where you sit and go through your
finances and maybe that would work for
some people I think a lot of people it
wouldn't but if it would great but if
not if it's just something that you talk
about if so if you like if you're the
person in the relationship who is
um reading or listening to podcasts or
whatever about this kind of thing trying
to bring that other person into it and
have conversations about it is really
helpful because it's very easy in a
couple to have one person who's going
off and like learning a load about
whatever it is and maybe they think that
they've decided that Bitcoin is the
future because they've read all the
stuff about it and the other person
might get to a point of agreeing but
because they haven't been on that whole
journey they're not just going to LEAP
straight there so you can't have to go
on that that journey together and keep a
light so if we have alignment in the
first place and then keep that alignment
nice what are your thoughts on joint
account versus your account versus
individual plus joints all that stuff
mad I don't know
um
I've been I'm very old I've been married
for a long time and it's very and so our
finances have been joined for a really
long time and so I'm just never really
thought about other ways of doing it I
don't know what what do most people do
uh I I don't know like I've been pulling
a few friends about this and listening
to a few podcasts about it one one way
is that both both parties have
individual bank accounts but then there
is also a shared one and they sort of
pay into it x amount every month
sometimes it's proportional to income
sometimes it's not depending on how
people feel about stuff and so you can
have a sort of your individual account
is for discretionary spending that you
don't have to get permission for like if
you wanted to buy a gift or like wanted
uh to buy a PS5 and you knew that you
know that would be your personal pot and
apparently that's nice because it means
that
you only have to discuss the bigger
things that affect you both as a couple
but like for little things like
discretionary spending on a PlayStation
in your case you may not have to get
quick permission for that which might
rub you up the wrong way like there's
all these different factors but I guess
how long have you been married for now
like 12 years
yeah so it's just everything goes into
one big part and you just don't think
too hard about it or yeah and it's I
don't know it's kind of it's probably
not their sensible like you know it's
it's probably not the sensible thing to
do but I don't know just kind of like
way into it like you know this is a when
we look together like eight years we got
married so it's like you know this is a
lifetime thing and so like it doesn't
matter it's all it all sorts itself out
but but there's lots of situations where
it's okay in the early days of a
relationship you probably don't want to
necessarily go and do that and then you
get situations like what you do for like
one person's earning way more than
someone else then does the person who's
not earning so much have to go to the
other one and ask for money like you
don't want that so yeah so yeah I don't
know how you crack it
um
if you're open to sharing uh are there
any uh any any instances in yours but I
guess 20 years of being together where
you've had friction related money in the
relation in the relationship hmm
and if not can you if and if not I guess
why not because like most people argue
about money apparently according to the
stats hmm
um
I can't think of any
foreign
marriage we just get on really well and
I don't don't argue about things but we
but I think like there has been like a
pro like processes of having to become
aligned on certain things and so I I had
to like I've kind of got this natural
kind of
scarcity mindset thing and so just so
I'm all I'm always I'd always be like
trying to trying to not spend money like
doing ridiculous things like walking for
half an hour instead of just spending a
pound for the bus and things like things
like that just don't make any sense and
my wife is far more well adjusted and so
I had to kind of get to uh I think we're
to to she had to kind of bring me over
to a point of going out look it's fine
you can you can do this and then like
doing things like um
um going and like we made a decision to
like go and rent a really a really
expensive flat to live in because you
wanted to and it took me a long time to
get there to get the final like okay
this doesn't make sense and like we
don't have to do this whatever but it's
the right thing to do and so we had to
kind of work our way through that
um but I ended up sort of like speaking
to friends about it and stuff and like
getting outside perspectives as well
because which I think is useful because
like when it comes because we are all
weird when it comes to money like
talking to different people about it
seeing how they do things is really
helpful yeah okay nice thank you um I
think that segues us nicely into uh
property so
you rent the flat that you live in yeah
that okay most people would say that's
money down the drain what the hell are
you doing yeah
um and that's wrong because I've done a
video about this um but when
why do why do I do it so I do it because
mainly it's um purely even if it didn't
make Financial sense
you could debate whether it does or not
um I would still rent because I want the
flexibility so I don't I just don't like
the idea of being tied into sub to
something so I like to I just like like
I just like freedom I like feeling that
I even if I don't want to do something I
could so if I want to go and live in a
different part of London a different
city a different country or whatever I
could go and do it with a couple of
months notice I'm probably not going to
do it but I could and that then that
means something but it's not able to do
that I would have to I'd have to wait
until it's old my house maybe it's not a
good time to sell my house and there's
not no I just don't want that so and I
also don't want their responsibility I
wanted to be someone else's problem if
something breaks and so they they have
to fix it so there's all these
psychological reasons and lots of people
have the exact opposite psychological
reason because like well I want to own
my house so I know that I have somewhere
that's mine that's stable that's blah
blah blah so you can't ultimately the
whole rent versus buy thing you can
never no no side can never win on that
because it comes down to these
psychological factors which people are
just going to have different motivations
on but on the financial side there are
situations
there are situations where you where it
can surprisingly be a better deal to
rent so I've on the case of where I'm
living I worked it out if I owned if I
owned where I live now as an investment
the return would be like something the
year would be something like two percent
so well I could get a better return
going investing in most other things and
so I would I'll do that instead of
looking up money in this asset that's
not earning anything
um
but also people I think what people miss
about this whole debate is
there's always you're always going to
have housing costs always it's
impossible not to so
if you're not paying pay money to a
landlord you're paying money to a bank
so when you make your interest payment
the majority of that especially in the
early years goes to paying the the
interest rather than paying down the
capital so you're either renting
property from a landlord or you're
renting money from the bank it's the
same thing even when you've paid your
mortgage off then you've still got
housing costs because as well as the
costs of upkeep and everything else
you've also got the opportunity cost of
what you could be doing with that money
so if you live in a million pound house
that's completely yours well that's
great you can't do anything with that
million quid except living it so it's
not really a lot of good whereas you
could instead go and invest that in
something else that produced a return
for you so it's really complex and I
think actually if you figure it all out
um homeowner you need homemanship come
out ahead for tax reasons for lots of
reasons but ultimately my position is
you have to own something you have to
own assets but you don't have to live in
your assets so you so I I own property
and I have all the benefits of capital
appreciation and your mortgage being
rated by inflation and all that good
stuff I just don't live in it yeah nice
I mean the the those are exactly my
reasons for renting a place in London uh
which is and I've also done a video
about this because
it was it was in a way of a video to try
and like because my mum would always be
like this is a terrible decision like
why don't you just work because I live
with my brother she'd be like why don't
you guys just buy flat in London and be
like okay well firstly like Where Do We
Begin like firstly we couldn't afford to
buy this place in London even if we
tried
and then and then to be like okay but
like the house like it doesn't have to
be so expensive like why not go into
zone six it's like well because it's
done six miles away and it's like right
now while we're young it's like we're
going to be in central London it's easy
to get people on the podcast we have
room for the podcast all of the
different things add up but I think the
way my mom thinks about things about
things into that psychological component
of like oh my goodness renting is money
down the drain and that is such a strong
like belief yeah and like getting on the
property ladder is like oh my God the
ultimate financial decision yeah
um I imagine you speak to a lot of
people who have those identical
worldviews
money down the drain getting on the
property ladder is the best thing you
can do yeah kind of thing there's a lot
of YouTube comments um
there's yeah you will never it's so
entrenched you'll you'll never change
anyone's mind like and I'm I'm not
interested in changing people's mind I
think it's just so it's like worth it if
someone's open to it to kind of
understand that there is a different
perspective
um but it's just so entrenched
there's not a lot you can do about it
but but I think the whole concept of a
property ladder doesn't really work
anymore because it used to be the case
that people would like go into a one
bedroom flat and then they'd maybe trade
up to two bed then move into a house it
doesn't happen anymore like first-time
buyers and by far the most typical
property for them to move into is a
three bed um it's a three-bit house and
so because people are doing everything
later in life and you often it's harder
to buy homes in your 30s by the time
you're doing it or whatever you kind of
move straight in there and often just
stay there forever so there's kind of
there is no kind of concept of of
trading up and so it's just yeah it just
doesn't you there are lots of reasons to
expose yourself to housing and all the
rest of it but if you if you don't know
for sure that you're going to be there
somewhere for a long time then the costs
are moving huge like the snap Duty like
if you bought a place in London the
stamp Duty on it would be extraordinary
and then if you decided three years
later you actually didn't want to be
there anymore then you'd end up paying
it all again somewhere else and so
that's the thing and so I think there's
lots of benefits to owning but then if
you really if you don't know for sure
that you're going to be in that place
for say five to ten years then it's
probably not going to work out and if
when when you're young and you want to
have all the options open to you do you
really want to be tied into one
particular geography because of this one
thing that you own yeah agreed um
how how much of a goal do you think it
should be for someone to buy their first
property whether or not it's whether or
not they live in it or don't live in it
tricky
um because
like Pro property
especially property with a mortgage for
some reason we talked about is just it's
just historically it's a great bet to
make because you've got even if property
only goes up in line with inflation the
fact that you've not put on you've not
put all the money in so you're
effectively leveraging inflation
so you're left so your so if you put
down like three chord if you put down a
quarter of the money and inflation is
two percent then your annual return will
be eight percent because you you don't
put all the money in so that's a pretty
good bet you're you're leveraging a
force that the government and their
Central Bank and the central bank and
everyone else is trying to make happen
so like along like along the way Peaks
crashes all this stuff will happen over
the very long term that is a great thing
to be exposed to but if you do it to own
then they'll drawbacks we just talked
about them and if you do it to invest in
then it's also really hard like if
you're invest being a being a landlord
I'm not expecting any violence to come
out at this point but it's hard in that
in that you're kind of you're taking a
lot of Financial Risk
like you're you're taking a huge amount
of money which for most people will like
take years and years and years and years
to save up and you're putting it all
into one asset so that's hard like if
you're not spending if you're not
nervous about that and you're not
spending a lot of time researching it
then you probably should be so it's
tough
um what what do you think of this whole
this whole stuff around like you often
hear the hear The Narrative of which is
true um you know it's impossible for
young people to get on to buy any
property these days because the prices
have gotten so high and then we're
ending ending up renting for forever and
things like that I guess it sort of
feeds back into our initial discussion
around like
there are no easy answers to this
problem yeah because the price goes up
because supply and demand and it's hard
to make houses and we can't just wave a
magic wand and 3D print a house yet
um people's salaries are not going up in
line with the prices of houses
uh for all sorts of reasons
of which some of them might be the
government is evil but like there are
all sorts of reasons beyond that and so
it actually is just genuinely hard to
get on the property ladder yeah
is it just one of those things that I
guess we just got to live with it
yeah it's one of those how do you solve
it when you wouldn't start from here
type problems it's just like I don't
it's it is harder
um there's but it's a matter of
it's been a matter of policy like we
kind of skirted over this but like when
um the 2008 financial crisis happened
the response to that was to print a load
of money
um and they then then basically the
effect that money went to people who
owned assets and the the that was it was
deliberate the idea is if you make asset
owners feel wealthy then they'll go and
spend money in the economy which will
then get the economy going again so it
was the point of that one of the points
of that was to make people who owned
assets more wealthy even wealthier and
so you've had like sort of 15 years of
that happening and so people if you if
you owned assets in 2008
great for you and if you didn't not so
great for you so so it's got way way
harder and I it's hard the way that
that's been kind of papered over right
now is um like longer mortgage terms so
like 20 of new mortgages are being taken
out for 35 plus years because that's the
way of spreading the payments out and
making it work
but there's got to be a limit at some
point like it's like in other countries
you get mortgages that your children
inherit so like you can go quite a long
way with it but I don't know I don't
know what the answer is it's hard yeah
and I guess for individuals who want to
you know prosper in a in a financial
system that's rigged against you uh I
you know the way I often think about
this is safe to get the emergency fund
step one step two
invest in yourself to boost your own
earning power ideally start a business
or a side Hustle
and now you've got money yeah now you're
and and now you're winning in this
financial system that's rigged against
you but for a lot of people the oh so
I've got to start my business is a
I mean it's just it's just the fastest
way and I suspect probably most reliable
way to actually make decent money unless
you're in Investment Banking or
something like that yeah which if you
are you would know it anyway exactly but
it's easier than easier said than done
but ultimately like you have to go and
let go of this idea that you that the
default path is not good uh there is a
part there's a time when the default
path was okay like you can go and you
could get a job that you could keep that
job forever that job would allow you to
have a decent standard of living and um
own your own home and everything else
and then you'd retire and you'd get a
pension and that would be great but that
default doesn't exist anymore like the
default now is that you you're living
standards are falling you can't afford
to own a home there probably isn't going
to be a pension by the time you're by
the time you're old so the default's no
good so you have to take responsibility
and change something which is it's
really hard to do but I think that's you
kind of have to get into that mindset
yeah yeah speaking of business what is
your portfolio of businesses look like
and because I guess like one thing that
really struck me about the property
podcast when I discovered it in like
2017 was that you guys were running the
Playbook of build a personal brand give
out content for free monetize it on the
back end and I was this was like six
months into my YouTube channel and I was
like oh I love what these guys are doing
I can see that these guys are really
switched on when it comes to the whole
building a business around a key person
of influence around a personal brand you
and you and the other Rob yeah so what
what does that look like and how did how
did it evolve over time a credit the
other Rob with all the clever stuff
around this but he he was always very
firm on giving everything away like give
give away all the knowledge and sell the
implementation and so yeah it allowed
you to and we allowed us to kind of like
move the free line a really long way
because like if you're selling courses
which is like the typical way people in
property monetize you're always having
to hold something back
um but um we didn't do that so um
because we were never selling anything
in that way people kind of trusted us
and so it was easy to build that up so
that's what we did for a long time
because the end the economics of the
business behind it because it's kind of
been through different iterations but
effectively we are making enabling high
value transactions for a small number of
people so because we you the economics
for each sale are really good we can
afford and it process because media is
kind of Costless in terms of
distribution we can have 99 listeners
who pay us nothing forever
for that one who does and that's fine
and it's great and everyone wins so
there's never any pressure for for us to
make it work and we've never we've never
run ads on our podcast or anything else
because well I would there's no there's
no point so we've been through kind of
different
we kind of followed the audience in
terms of what they wanted and so we
built up an audience like what do you
want well you want a letting agency so
we started by the way as you know and um
I imagine that's quite a hard business
yeah turns out really hard where you're
like being like squeezed on the margins
because people are price sensitive on
that particular front and yeah
everything not a good business that's
probably why you sold it yeah tough
tough the good thing about it is it's
sticky so it's like you you're it's it's
you you kind of you get a client once
and you can keep them for years and
years and years
um but it's tough operationally really
hard and the margins are not good
um but then when we started we had like
um like a tax consultancy for a while
we're kind of following the audience and
then I had I had a call with one of your
attacks in front of like many years ago
yeah it was quite helpful it's like a
one-off thing yeah um and that was just
like there's nothing wrong with the
economics of that but it's just kind of
we would we just ended up like
stretching ourselves really thin
um because we were doing like the
classic thing that you're meant to do
which is like well you know you build up
an audience you find out what they want
um Turned out what they wanted was a lot
and so we tried to do a lot so it was
just kind of too much yeah so we've now
we've kind of divested all that stuff
and gone back to something the real core
of it is like we give away all the
education we do all that and I love
doing that um and then behind it we've
got property I've investor business you
know about that helps people uh buy
property and they've also got a fund
which is newer which is to basically
enable people to buy buy into a property
portfolio with a far smaller amount of
money so that's they're two different
kind of models but they're both based
around the same core thing which is just
investing we know how to invest that's a
bit we can do all this operationally
really hard stuff yeah let's not do that
yeah we've really had the same exact
same realization with our business where
when we try and do too many things
because they are the right things to
they feel like the right things to do
because people are asking for them and
because you know when the audience says
they want something it's like great
let's give it to them etc etc
just like the hard stuff is just just a
bit of a faff and a bit of a faff at
scale when running business as you know
is uh in an enormous bath and it takes
Focus away from the small amount of
things that are driving the most value
definitely and as why do why did you get
into this in the first place why did I
get into it we like creating stuff and
yeah teaching and teaching educational
stuff and writing educational books and
yes so if you didn't spend all your time
dealing with a load of aggro and stuff
which is nothing to do with that then
then
yeah how big is your team like what does
the business look like
um it's about 40 people 4-0
what did they broadly do
um property is annoying as you know and
so um we've got a team of people who are
involved in getting the um or getting
transactions through so from the point
of saying yes I want to buy this
property to actually owning it we've got
to have to hold people's hands through
that process I really appreciated that
that's part of the process yeah that's
for me that's the like the the selling
point is supposed to be like we get you
a discount and we put the property for
you and that's all great but I think the
actual hand holding is a really big part
of it
um
so that's the whole team
um there's a whole team around that
there's a sales team so that people
you'll speak to who actually will like
go through your strategy with you in the
first place
um there's a lot of Finance because of
the fund and so we've got we've got a
whole a whole Finance team with
accountants and all the rest of it
um and just lots of other oh we've got
the the team who goes out and actually
finds a necessity investments in the
first place and then lots of other stuff
and like hrit all that kind of stuff and
so it's um it adds up to a lot it's
relatively it doesn't sound it but it's
relatively lean but there's just there's
just so much going on that that
um it's not the kind of business you
couldn't run it with three people it's
not possible and if you got rid of if
you if you only did the invest business
and got rid of the uh property fund
stuff what would that
so you could then
you kind of you'd lose like bits or
you'd lose kind of like some finance and
compliance and all that sort of thing so
I don't know I don't know what
proportion of the business would be but
you could definitely you could
definitely slim it down somewhat and
then what's your and the other Rob's
role in the business
those
um it's evolved in a big way over time
and it started out with us kind of
figuring out as we went along and we
kind of like buy default you were kind
of joint CEOs which is a terrible idea
because then it's just like everything
is either both of your problem or you
both leave it for each other so
shouldn't do that
um but then
um then we've all been I've we've been
through lots of different iterations of
air where we're each looking after
different parts
um where we've now got to is go to my
happy place where I'm mostly doing the
education part of it and doing the
newsletter and the YouTube channel and
all that kind of thing and the other Rob
is the actual CEO and so he has book
ultimate responsibility for running the
business but we've now been doing it for
such a long time that we've eventually
worked our way around to a place where
we've got a really good team so a lot of
the stuff just happens and that took a
long time to get to a long long time
yeah it takes ages to get to a place
where you feel like yes things things
are working things are and I don't I
don't know how you I don't know how you
find the right people other than just
like have a lot of the wrong people and
keep the ones who work out but we kind
of ended up with like an amazing team
and some of whom have been with us for
like eight years and stuff and got us
like absolute Superstars but I don't
know how you find the Superstar every
time yeah we have and we we now have a
very extensive interview process but
it's also ideal and I guess for for you
as well like for us we can recruit from
our audience yeah
because it's like I speak to friends who
run companies and they're like oh man
recruiting is so hard I'm like really oh
oh yeah okay I guess it is if you don't
have so much inbound yeah that's the
best thing like yeah there's a pre-built
filter which is another great widget
which is so great about the whole
content things it goes for your for your
audience as well just like your and your
your customers are kind of pre-selected
as well like you're you're not going to
have that many customers I imagine who
are a nightmare to deal with because
they've been filtered through your world
view already yeah they're kind of your
type of person and when I hang out with
them in real like we did we did a
meet-up in Austin last week for like 80
80 of our previous students they're all
great yeah those great Vibes they're
sort of people who Vibe with my stuff
makes similar kind of content they want
to be YouTubers they have businesses
like I just love these people this is
what you want um any tips for someone
listening who uh is interested in
setting up a sort of business like this
where it's like your content free free
content
you know I I in in my head I call it the
9911 rule which is 99 of the content is
free one percent is paid for the one
percent who can afford it or something
to that oh one percent off services for
the one percent who can afford it um
like I'd much rather like I love the
fact that we charge 5K for our course
but our implementation e-course yeah for
a tiny number of people which funds the
entire business to be able to give all
the content for free to everyone else
yeah exactly um yeah so any tips for
someone who loves that the idea of that
business model
um
I'm not sure because we've just kind of
it just kind of happened and I don't
know how I would now go and do it
intentionally it's one of those things
where if you kind of tell the story if
you tell the story in retrospect it all
makes perfect sense but I don't know how
you do it from scratch I think that
I would definitely encourage that model
because I think it's it's more
sustainable than any other way of doing
it that I'm aware of and it just avoids
any kind of it allows people to have all
the stuff but nine percent of the stuff
for free which is great you don't have
to worry about arbitrarily drawing a
line somewhere which is amazing it means
you can out-compete everyone who is
trying to hold back
um
I suppose that you'd have to have to
make really sure that there is a
business there and it has to be like
high value high margin High whatever to
to make it work so you wouldn't want to
spend years like that building a
business and then realize when you try
to charge that one percent for something
that actually that I want it or they
don't charge enough to make it work yeah
but do you see any examples interesting
examples of like your students doing
things like that
yeah
um essentially the business model that
most educational channels that I know go
down is exactly that
um but where most of the content S3 some
of the content is paid uh but then you
get into the the issue of where do you
draw the line uh one way of getting
around that is don't draw the line at
all and just charge for implementation
yeah but I think the other way of
getting around that line is by saying
you know what we're just going to give
everything away for free slowly over
time but when we when we make a course
we put it all together in one place we
give the worksheets the the tangible
assets or the somewhat intangible assets
bundled together and so yes technically
someone could find out all this
information by looking on the internet
but what they're paying for is the uh
curation they're paying for saving time
and they're paying for the support
options we offer along the way to kind
of hold their hand yeah because actually
holding someone's hand is a ridiculously
valuable thing when they're buying a
property as I've been handheld by Jawad
one of your team members yeah uh or but
also when starting a YouTube channel
like our team holds people's hands
through the process because it's
actually quite hardened quite like
emotionally hard rather than like
conceptually hard
um and so all of those I think are ways
to monetize the education business yeah
then we see people who are and we're
trying to go into this ourselves you
know you could release physical products
uh that's a whole faff but then it does
mean you have a business that's
potentially salable you can make an app
apps with subscription Revenue seem to
be like a great thing but the startup
costs are absolutely enormous and it's
hard to compete with apps yeah uh which
are more of a commodity than other
things so the pros and cons of every
business model but yeah I think I still
think it's a great a great way to to
make money it's weird isn't it you can
ask someone to pay for an app what no
apps are free then you ask people to
spend five grand for a course yeah of
course
it's weird like the the people who spend
five grand on our course we say Hey you
know we'd recommend vid IQ Chrome
extension oh is that free dude come on
who cares
yeah I think it's great it's a great
great model and it's it's worked really
well for us and it works really well for
others but do you think about how much
you are tied up and they're like is your
business is your business salable and do
you care uh it's not salable and I also
don't care
um because
I think someone would have to have to
offer me a stupidly large amount of
money to part with it yeah and even then
I would really consider it because if I
think what would I do if I had all the
money in the world I'd still make
YouTube videos and I still do a podcast
because it's just cool yeah um I
probably wouldn't sell courses that's
the only thing that we that I wouldn't
do if I had all the money in the world
um
but having said that we are trying to
and and so partly this is why I'm keen
on the property thing because it is a
thing that is completely Decor related
to my popularity on the internet yeah
but also why we want to build a
productivity app and like Tech
accessories because those are
potentially sellable and just as you
said having the option to know you could
sell it if you wanted to but even if you
don't want to take the option there's
something nice about having that freedom
yeah which currently we don't have
because it's all tied to my personal
brand interesting what about for you
guys I I think
that there's a way of making it salable
but got no interest in doing that yeah
so anytime soon because I think with uh
with the fund like we've deliberately
given it a different brand and we've and
we're it's like it comes to a point
where it's like it's it's it's its own
thing like there are reasons there are
reasons for investing in it which are
completely different from
the where the podcast guys and so I
think like it's almost a point like we
are uh almost like we're advertising the
fund or we're an affiliate for the fund
or whatever but it's like that's not
that's not us and so we're trying to
create a kind of Separation just because
that seems to kind of make sense nice
but for the most part I've got no
problem with being the being a podcast
guy and the podcast guy yeah well Rob
thank you very much for being the
podcast guy you've uh helped me get into
property investing which has been uh of
a somewhat fun Journey somewhat uh but
I'm sure I will be even more thankful
for uh thankful for it as things
compound over time and thank you so much
for coming on the show thank you for
having me all right so that's it for
this week's episode of Deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are going to be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the iTunes Store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full HD or
4k on YouTube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching I do hit subscribe
button if you aren't already and I'll
see you next time bye